thank you and welcome my name is Kirk
colon Brander I'm vice president and
secretary of the MIT corporation thank
you all for joining us here today for
what I think will be a wonderful
conversation between president rife and
Sal Khan and we'll follow that
conversation with the time for Q&A with
all of you the event was made possible
with the help of start labs an MIT
student group dedicated to spreading
entrepreneurship throughout MIT and
other universities start labs helps
students create their own companies and
works and helps them work with existing
startups you can check out start labs
org for more information I also want to
thank general catalyst partners and in
particular Bilal and amant for their
help in making this event happen some
members of start labs will be helping me
moderate the Q&A session that will
follow we're going to be using Twitter
for question submissions so if you want
to use hashtag Salle MIT you can send us
your questions so again it's hashtag
Salle MIT one word to submit any
questions that you have for Sal
following the conversation with
president rife we're fortunate to
participate in a conversation between
those two gentlemen let me introduce
them to you very briefly president rice
is concluding his first year as MIT s
17th president prior to July 1 president
rice served as mi t--'s provost for
seven years and in his final year as
Provost we saw two major announcements
for MIT on the future of online learning
the first was the launch of MIT X and
then of edx a partnership founded by MIT
and Harvard University for Sal I first
met Sal Khan in the summer of 1997 the
end of his junior year at MIT he was a
participant at MIT leadership
which is a leadership development
program that we run each year for
approximately 60 MIT undergraduates the
following year he and I worked closely
in a seminar that I ran that and it gave
me the opportunity to see the
extraordinary creativity and commitment
that Sal brings to his work and to his
life Sal Grave graduated the next year
in June of 1998 with three MIT degrees
two SBS one in mathematics and one in
EECS and an M ng in EECS and since he
was the senior class president at the
time he had the privilege of receiving
those three diplomas from MIT s
commencement speaker that year who was
the president of United States Bill
Clinton I mention that because it was
just 14 years later last June that Sal
himself was mi t--'s commencement
speaker he stood at the podium on
Killian Court and talked with our
graduates and their families about his
career path since MIT that first took
him to Silicon Valley as a technologist
and then as a hedge fund analyst
following an MBA at Harvard Business
School but it was what he did next that
put Sal on our commencement stage last
June and on this stage today in 2004 in
a side-project Sal began tutoring his
young cousin in math communicating by
phone and using an interactive notepad
others took an interest so Sal began
posting videos on YouTube you all know
the rest demand took off and in 2009 Sal
quit his day job to commit himself fully
to the not-for-profit Khan Academy
according to a Forbes article last
November over the past two years the
more than 3400 Khan Academy videos have
been viewed by more viewed more than 200
million times this the site is used by 6
million unique students each month who
have collectively solved more than 750
million problems that's about 2 million
a day
and the material which is provided at no
cost is formally or informally part of
the curriculum in 20,000 classrooms
around the world Sal was naturally a
keynote speaker at a summit meeting
entitled online learning and the future
of residential education that MIT and
Harvard co-hosted about eight weeks ago
that summit brought together academic
and other online learning experts to
consider the opportunities that exist
for efforts such as MIT X and EDX
60-minutes recently profiled Sal let's
watch a brief clip to help complete my
introduction of Sal Khan here we go take
a moment and remember your favorite
teacher
now imagine that teacher could reach not
30 kids in a classroom but millions of
students all over the world that's
exactly what Sal Khan is doing on his
website Khan Academy with digital
lessons and simple exercises he's
determined to transform how we learn at
every level one of his most famous
pupils Bill Gates says Khan this teacher
to the world is giving us all a glimpse
of the future of Education it all
started in 2004 when Sal Khan was
working as a hedge fund analyst in
Boston and his cousin Nadia a seventh
grader in New Orleans was struggling
with algebra he agreed to tutor her
remotely and wound up posting lessons on
YouTube they helped Nadia but then an
odd thing happened total strangers
started using them too I started getting
feedback like you know my child has
dyslexia and this is the only thing
that's getting into him I got letters
from people saying you know we're
praying for you and your family that's
pretty heady stuff you know people don't
say that type of stuff to a hedge fund
analyst normally so in 2009 Khan quit
his job and working from a desk set up
in his closet devoted himself full-time
to Khan Academy it's a nonprofit with a
simple but audacious mission to provide
a free world-class education for anyone
anywhere if that goal sounds far-fetched
for a guy working in his closet consider
what happened next there's a website
that I've just been using
my kids recently called Khan Academy ka
Chan just one guy doing some
unbelievable 15-minute tutorials I was
like those videos for Nadia not Bill
Gates I look at some of the stuff that's
right
Bill Gates one of the smartest and
richest men in the world was using Sal
Khan's free videos to teach his own kids
that was just two years ago today with
the help of more than 15 million dollars
in funding much of it from the Gates
Foundation in Google so if we get rid of
the % we moved the decimal over he's
amassed a library of math lectures 12
plus 4 is 16 starting with basic
addition and building all the way
through advanced calculus we're taking
the limit as Delta X approaches zero the
exact same thing but he's not just a
math whiz he has this uncanny ability to
break down over the most complicated
subjects including physics biology
astronomy medicine in just a couple of
years he's gone from having a few
hundred pupils to more than 4 million
every month has it sunk in to you that
you are probably the most watched
teacher in the world now yeah I you know
I I try not to say things like that to
myself you don't want to think about it
too much because it can I think paralyze
you a little bit Khan has been able to
hire with competitive salaries some of
the most talented engineers and
designers in the country the Khan
Academy office has the intense vibe of a
Silicon Valley startup the team is
working to create software they hope
will transform how math is taught in
American classrooms Khan Academy has
created a dashboard so teachers like
Courtney Cadwell can monitor each
student's progress so right now they're
all working on things and you can see
that real-time yes so as you sit here
and look at the dashboard you see how
the students are doing individually you
see how they're doing is a whole class
and you can figure out who you need to
help exactly and here I can track their
progress over time I can see who's
rushing ahead who's lagging behind I can
see if they begin to stagnate a blue bar
indicates a student knows a concept
Orange they're still working on it but
if a red bar pops up it's kind of the
red flag to tell me hey it's time to
step in
you know bean and I can see no so you
can see not only that that's red but
specifically what the problem is and you
can see the number of seconds they spent
on each problem Eric Schmidt the
pioneering chairman of Google says he's
seen a lot of failed attempts to
integrate technology into education but
says what Sal Khan is doing is different
many many people think they're doing
something new but they're not really
changing the approach where's with Saul
he said what we're going to do is not
only are going to make these interesting
10 minute videos but we're going to
measure whether it works or not he was
the guy to sort of make this happen why
do you think it was him and not some
person who was an educator who had a
background in this area innovation never
comes from the established institutions
it's always a graduate student or a
crazy person or somebody with a great
vision Saul is that person in education
in my view but no matter how big or how
successful Khan Academy gets Sal Khan
promises you'll never put a price tag on
it the for-profits have to mold
themselves much more to the education
establishment than we do as a
not-for-profit we're like what's our
mission to educate children as well as
possible I've said it enough times and
it's in our mission statement a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere
[Applause]
are you doing so very good it's a pretty
cool video there oh yeah
I just want to start by thanking you for
being with us how we're really honored
and delighted to have you here so look I
spent the whole night thinking about the
toughest questions I can ask him so why
don't we start let's go
so you were an undergrad and I grad
student here at MIT
so how has that influenced you what did
you take out of being here those years
yeah no I mean influenced me that and
I'm probably speaking for a lot of the
folks here I mean I I went to kind of a
standard public high school in in in
Metairie Louisiana and you know it's I I
was the first person from I believe from
my school to ever go to MIT and it was
you know one incredibly intimidating
when you come here but incredibly
exciting at the same time where you're
you're you come here and you know what
some of the stereotypes are true I mean
the people here are incredibly smart
incredibly hard-working incredibly
professionals particularly yeah right
what the professors of course yes yes
but but I think I think some of the
stereotypes don't hold true I I found
that this is one of the most warm places
ever and I really felt like I was coming
into a community and you know I'll tell
you it you know within a week of showing
up on this campus from Metairie
Louisiana it like opened my mind it
opened my mind to what was possible you
know you meet students grad students
professors who don't think in terms of
you know how do I tactically solve the
next small problem they're solving big
problems they they're not afraid of it I
mean most of the world if you say you
want to tackle a big problem well you're
crazy but here you know you use bump
people in the hallway and and and that's
where they naturally think they
naturally think in kind of the grandest
terms so there's that I mean I think it
it this is an intense place I mean
there's no you know sugarcoating that
but that intensity I think forms really
strong bonds between the people here and
it really you know half the time you get
a project at MIT you're like I'm not
gonna be able to do that by next week
that's crazy but then you actually do it
and and it really creates a different
mindset that a lot of these seemingly
impossible problems are actually very
very doable and actually now when I even
in in the real world now
I can often pick an MIT person out based
on kind of an unwillingness to say that
they can't do something so so yeah I
mean I could go on I gave the coming I
mean III get I get water yard when I
come here I mean it's it's it's yeah
thank you thank you let me just go to do
something related to that so it's been a
few years since you left and you've
learned quite a bit and you've done a
great deal can you think of something
that you wish you learn what you were
here I mean this is kind of an advice
for all of us in the room all of these
students here I mean something that you
wish you had done we should study while
you were here yeah no I mean it's I mean
you know I think everyone who's you know
10 15 years out of college which is they
paid a little bit more attention and in
one class or two now that that way that
actually does show up in the real world
but but yeah I mean I I you know III
actually well you know what are they you
know I don't know I don't have that many
regrets so to speak from from my
experience here I mean I I mean I guess
there are good things that I wish I did
even more of I was very active in
student government in fact Lee that was
some of the best learning that I had
here of just you know how organizations
work how people work yeah III you know I
think you know if I had to say some one
thing maybe that you know I I think
coming out I you know I can't I can't
critique my my Pat my path that I took
because it got me here and I'm having
the time of my life and I'm able to
pursue my passions and so one
possibilities maybe I could have done
that earlier but III but I I have no
regrets about you know what what
happened here was I met my wife here
I've no regrets about that what what do
you think is the secret of the success
of Khan Academy I mean video instruction
existed before you and and you came in
and the whole thing exploded with with
Khan Academy so and and and you
triggered a lot of other things
including our own activity with MIT is
on the attack so in your view what's the
success what's the secret of that
success you know I don't know for sure I
mean some of it might have already been
like right time right place but you know
I wasn't the first person to think of
video education yeah yeah you know you
could go back to the radio people
thought that was gonna be the killer app
in education if you can broadcast
lectures the television oh and now we
can see the teacher VCR now it's on
demand and and you know even in the in
the late 90s early 2000s the internet
was all about exchange of information so
there was this big boom in hey we're
gonna do online education I actually
credit MIT to a large degree a lot of
people here might not remember but
around 1999-2000 a lot of universities
were partnering and trying to monetize
online degrees and their course content
and then MIT essentially laid the
gauntlet down and I think it was 2000 or
2001 said no we we think it's our
responsibility to share this with the
world and they did OpenCourseWare and so
OpenCourseWare was was out in 2000 even
by 2006 when I started making videos
there was already I was like the I
wasn't the first person on YouTube I was
probably the hundredth person on YouTube
to make videos if I had to guess what
what allowed it to get traction and
resonate I think you know I can't
understate the fact that I was doing it
for my cousin's the the fact that I was
their tutor I had a human connection
with them when I was making the videos I
wasn't you know I actually think I would
have messed up if the first videos I
thought I was doing it for Bill Gates
III I think I would have fallen to the
path that a lot of content creators fall
into Wow if a million people are gonna
watch this if we're very influential
people I have to make this really
professional and perfect and so what you
start doing is you say okay I'm gonna
get a team of script writers I'm gonna
get a team of computer graphics
engineers get them together I'm gonna
get you know James Earl Jones to read
the script actually it's not just a
Jamesville Jones it's usually the person
who created your GPS device and you know
the end product you'll see these these
you know CGI molecules and you'll hear
the next step in photosynthesis is when
the mitochondria and it sounds like your
GPS device and it's not like something
that you can connect with it looks
professional but doesn't feel very human
and you know some of those early videos
I thought is really for my cousins
I go you know a minute into a problem
like wait maybe okay wait I had the
wrong intuition here let me back up and
I left it in there
IIIi said it's just for Nadia Arman
Arman is coming next year by the way
right the second student of Khan Academy
very very I'm making sure he has some
friends when he shows up but but I think
that created a human connection the
other people who found it said hey this
is some guy like it sounds like he's
talking to his cousin's because because
he was talking to his cousin's so very
conversational very focused on intuition
I mean one thing that I felt growing up
and I think this is probably true of a
lot of people and places like MIT who
have done well in math and science is
that we early on in life we're very
obsessed with understanding it at a very
deep level you know when the teacher
taught us in second grade how to regroup
or borrow we weren't happy with the
algorithm we just said wait wait why
does that work how can I borrow a one
from the eighth and make it a ten why
does that work and and we were answering
those questions for ourselves the whole
time not realizing that was going to pay
huge dividends when we get to high
school and we went to college and for my
cousin's I saw that a lot of them might
have been missing that in their
education and I was trying to give them
that intuition these connected things
between the concepts so it was that you
know I think it just might have been the
sheer amount of content that you know
hey this guy helped me through algebra
he's got trigonometry videos too hey
he's got finance videos and whatever
else so I don't know it might be all of
the above a word-of-mouth I think I
think that's a good lesson you just you
just described something interesting
which is how you are you did the videos
talking to somebody so the receiver is
actually feeling that you're talking to
that person that that's that's that's a
very unusual that's a very good
explanation you have said several times
that that you will only make can Academy
videos if you have an intuition about
how to teach that concept so can you
tell us more about that and it does not
limit you it does let me I mean I will
say that there is a there are several
topics for us like well you know this is
a topic that a lot of people need to
understand I don't have an intuition
today so I can't do it but let me spend
a week just immersing myself sometimes
I'm successful I say is clicking I can
start to
to draw the connections that can call up
some friends who can help me draw those
connections but sometimes I fail so for
me I I won't make video unless I'm
excited about making the video so one I
have to feel like when I finally get
this subject and organic chemistry was
one of them that you know the first pass
I kind of was able to do it but I said
look if I'm gonna start making organic
chemistry videos I have to really
understand general themes and patterns
and intuitions here and that when I did
click but you know I'm still working on
quantum physics and I'm we might I might
have to get some some other folks some
other folks to help I guess some people
said there is no intuition but anyway
but but yes so so I think that's key and
I think it's also key to really enjoy
the subject matter you know whenever
some people ask me what's your favorite
videos like the one I'm about to do
that's the one that where my mind is I'm
excited about it right now I've been
doing a lot of history videos in my mind
history is the most exciting thing and
it is that I could be doing and you know
earlier today someone asked me well you
know what do you do to prepare for a
video and I make sure I understand it at
a deep level I make sure I have I'm a
very visual person so I try to visually
that's why the diagramming always appeal
to me I always wanted to diagram things
but then I'd say look before you make a
video force yourself to smile and force
yourself to laugh and if you do those
two things that that energy is going to
carry off into the video let's talk
about the impact that they can Academy
may be doing and other outgrowth of that
activity too to the classroom
environment do you think we'll ever had
a chance for an opportunity to actually
change what we do in the classroom do
you think that would ever happen and you
know we're trying to do experiments like
that and and if that were possible what
will the role of the teacher be in that
in that future yeah well you know the
answer I mean to some degree you you
guys are part of that answer you know we
started off in 2010 with our first
funding in a local school district
reached out and said what would you do
with a math classroom we said hey
lecture can happen at students own time
and pace and this is coming from a guy
who made a bunch of lectures we said
look we think lecture is not the most
important part of the learning process
the most important part of the learning
process is problem solving peer tutoring
doing things with your hands
so the classroom should be about working
at your own pace peer tutoring each
other the teacher sitting next to
students leading students through
projects and so we started to see these
ideas and in and you know not more than
a handful now of classrooms around the
country mainly but even around the world
and and what's exciting is this idea I
you know I've given talks to groups of
teachers faculty members there no one
has actually pushed back on that idea no
one said no no I think the lecture is
the most important part of the learning
process no one has said oh no I think
all students should learn at the same
pace never gotten pushed back on any of
these things and so hopefully we are and
this idea isn't it's an old one this you
know mastery-based learning self-paced
learning it's hundreds of years it
probably predates our current school
system and so I'm hoping that we are a
catalyst for this to become a more
mainstream idea and you know in my
opinion MIT and Harvard and MIT acts
Harvard acts EDX the reason why that's I
mean it's exciting for a bunch of
reasons one is just dissemination of
information courses whatever but if MIT
changes what happens on this campus if
Harvard changes what happens on their
campus and the lecture hall over time is
not the main focus of a classroom then
MIT and Harvard are defining what
excellence is for the rest of the world
every engineering school in the country
looks at MIT and says what what should
we look like to say the minute you guys
say you know we're not giving lectures
anymore I think in five years you won't
have an engineering school in the in the
world that gives lectures anymore as
soon as that happens the high school say
well what is excellence they look at
universities like this say whoa gee
that's the best in the world we're doing
something different and then they're
going to emulate so I think it'll be
from both directions we're kind of the
bottoms up one teacher at a time but you
know there's 30,000 classrooms using
Khan Academy now but you guys are the
you know everyone wants to wear the
jeans that you know Jennifer Lopez wears
and that's the kind of I don't know if
that was a good analogy that was yeah
Humason self-paced learning cell so you
know I've I've heard people who are
critical of this kind of stuff that
we're trying to do and and they say well
that that just really worked for for
motivated students so what do we say to
that what about everybody else yeah you
know actually when I started doing all
this I was making these resources for my
cousin's and these exercises and learn
at your own pace
I kind of was in that camp I was like
you know this is gonna work for someone
who really wants to learn I was
imagining a 12 or 13 year old version of
me or frankly probably most of the
people in this room my cousins were
having trouble with a few concepts but
they were motivated but what we found is
if you let students work at their own
pace and initially and this is you know
going back to the last question we're
not saying when we say learn at your own
pace we're not saying learn by yourself
it's in fact the opposite right now when
everyone is learning together it's
actually very isolating you could be in
a room of 300 people but you actually
don't talk to them it's actually just
about you you know maybe if you've got
some good friends right before finals
you'll have a study group button during
the classroom it's a very it's just
about you you're alone the professor's
way over there and so when we say learn
at your own pace it's not learn by
yourself so you're in a classroom other
people can help you if you have problems
the teacher is there and you know I
inadvertently sat next to Wendy Kopp of
Teach for America a couple of months ago
and I asked her you know what is the
determinant of your really good teachers
and she said you know it would surprise
you it's not the best lecturers I mean
that's helpful if they can organize
information and lecture it our best
teachers the ones that consistently move
the dial are the ones that form bonds
with students and change the students
mindsets that coached them to say look
this is about you and your
responsibility of your own learning I'm
here to help you and so in my mind it's
not about being alone anymore and and
the role of the teacher becomes far more
valuable in this world I think that's
the important message to convey you
mentioned at 60 minutes about your
decision to make notes for profit that
that that's not a trivial decision you
know just think of it Cal economy could
be worth a ton of money today
I could be dressed a little bit better
what why did you do it that way
you know I'll say and it was it was kind
of a I mean there was a bunch of things
going going on
I mean Juana and I say this 100%
genuinely well the day that I read that
press release and this was in 2001 I was
literally you know I was working at a
start-up in San Francisco and I remember
the day literally why I read about MIT
like just taking a stand and saying like
look this isn't about profit this isn't
about it this is about and it was almost
like MIT did as a gut reaction didn't
say hey what's gonna happen long term it
said no we just believe that this should
be for everyone and it did it and
frankly that was like one of the most
proud days of my life that has a clown I
love being part of this community and
when people started to approach and you
know and obviously they started with me
not thinking I wasn't you know I used to
go to dinner parties in like 2006-2007
and and and show what I was doing to my
friends and they're like oh but how you
gonna make money off this no no no this
is just a hobby I mean I have a job
they're like what's the business my side
no there is no business model I mean I
just want to do this and you're there
kind of looking in my MBA friends look
at me a little suspiciously like what
happened to Sal but I was getting so
much emotional reward from these letters
people were sending even today several
of the students here said you know Khan
Academy helped them get into MIT I mean
that was that's better than anything and
so in 2008 there were some venture
capitalists that reached out very good
people but something you know the first
conversation was always a good one it
was hey look we can give you funding
right now you can quit your job you can
do this full-time we'll always keep this
free and then we'll figure out how to
make me you know monetize it it would be
a business but meetings two and three
did get they they weren't bad ideas but
they just didn't feel right to me
personally which is hey well how about
you know the algebra stuff is free but
your SAT prep you know because that's
high value we can we can charge for that
or how about the accounting stuff we can
charge for how about we put ads only in
this part of the site and one that felt
a little bit I didn't feel good and then
on top of that I and that forced me to
really think it through I mean my day
job was a hedge fund analyst all I did
is I talked to
people about their capital structure
their motivations who their investors
are what's that making them do and I
thought about well and this was
delusional at this point I mean I was
one guy not even our full-time operating
out of a closet yet and I said well
what's a home run in the for-profit
sector well a home run is you grow
incredibly fast and that's good a lot of
people will use the content and that you
either get acquired or you IPO and both
of those things weren't so clear to me
as positives if you get acquired what
are they gonna do with the content maybe
if I'm the owner I can control it but
what are they gonna do what maybe my
kids inherited what are my spoiled kids
gonna do with all of this this content
they might sell it off or or do
something if it gets acquired it might
get put behind some closet someplace and
no one ever sees it and then I thought
about well what's a home run as a
not-for-profit and and you're thinking
of a home run as a not-for-profit is a
little bit more of an epic thought
process like well a home run is gee
maybe this could be maybe a hundred
years and this was really delusional
this could be like another MIT this
could be like another Stanford you know
maybe my great-great grandkids could use
this maybe and you know five hundred
years people could still use Khan
Academy and you know I actually did some
you know there are no institutions other
than not-for-profits that have been able
to stay true for their mission
multi-generation multi-century and and
and that just felt more epic and more
cool maybe able to reach more people and
so that was kind of the initial thinking
well you saw with all those sensors let
me tell you we're very proud of you
no no I'm very proud of you you're doing
very good yourself your
and number there is too much better
dress yeah you must have had a few exits
before you mentioned money management
before before you decided to do this did
you experience any culture shock you
know where you're spending the day he's
thinking about money and then evenings
thinking about not money
yeah and eventually you jumped well you
know it's interesting and you know when
people when you say hedge fund it it
triggers certain neurons in people's
brain they kind of imagine Gordon Gekko
or boiler room or you know something in
these traders and these suits that was
not what I was doing I was working for
one gentleman a Dan wool and his dog
Otto he was our chief economist and you
know we literally we would show up we
would have a bunch of call scheduled
with a bunch of companies of different
you know one could be an egg producer
the next would be a software company the
next one would be a railroad next one
would be you know a retail or a mall
based retailer and my job was and it's I
don't think this was very traditional
for a hedge fund and every hedge fund is
different my job was to lead that
conversation so well my job was first to
prepare for that to really understand
the egg business through and through and
then be able to talk to the CEO or the
CFO of that while my boss was listening
and analyzing their business and I just
had a spreadsheet there and I was
analyzing in the first half hour was
just like oh well this is you know this
is a fun business and if you explain it
in the second half I was like what you
told me a B and C but that doesn't add
up to D what you've told people and then
living the CFO hem and haw a little bit
and then me you know and that my boss is
like you know trading rise but but so so
it was actually an incredibly
intellectual experience because my job
was literally every day I had to learn
about five new industries and
communicate about those five new
industries in real time with the
management team and with and with my
boss and my boss was actually a very he
was in it I think more for the
intellectual challenge of it than the
money and I mean in 2008
he could be right now running he's one
of the I you know I could tell you his
returns it's one of the best returns
people have ever seen at a very small
scale
he could right now be managing billions
of dollars if he wants to he took time
off in 2008 to spend more time with his
family because his child had just born
so you know we were on the west coast at
two o'clock he used to tell me look Sal
it's not about working hard it's about
working smart go home have a life and if
he didn't do that there you know there'd
be no there'd be no Khan Academy so my
hedge flood the headphone I worked for
was the exact opposite of what people
what was funny when 60-minutes Cannes oh
my god you have some pictures of your
hedge fund yeah I have a few no no we
want even like a suit like you know like
I was like no I don't have a suit and I
finally dug up that one picture and it
was like at a wedding or something it
wasn't get work there was a funny day
where we had an investors come to the
the fund with some of our major
investors and right before they came my
boss Kent came in it's like you know Sal
I'm normally not like you know I'm not
normally a stickler about this but you
know could you at least wear pants I was
wearing shorts I mean I wasn't like like
I mean that would be unprofessional even
by my standards
so Khan Academy is extremely good at
helping people learn and in fact that
she said some of some of people in the
audience cut there might be things to me
but what about credentials what about
just giving a piece of paper that shows
them that they actually learn do you
have any plans for that or what's your
view about that yeah so so that's
something that we think a lot about and
I write a lot about it in the book and
and and one we do want to explore you
know you learned how to run Khan Academy
how do you prove it and you know is
there a place where you could take a
diagnostic and a you know we can already
do that on Khan Academy we can give you
a badge but maybe it's your older sister
taking it for you so we do want to see
is there a way to authenticate validate
that you were the person it might be
your teacher Proctor's it or you do some
other technology to do it but but we
want to explore and I write about this
is you know that's only one dimension of
someone's what someone is capable of
they're their academic dimension their
SAT score whatever you want to call it
but there are other dimensions that are
equally or I would argue more important
one is your ability to communicate and
and come and talk to people and teach
the
and so we could imagine a reality and
you know even on Khan Academy today our
profiles you can see how people have
participated in conversations and I
often times I go to someone's profile
and I'm like wow that person is really
like you can you can see they're
thoughtful they can communicate they
understand what the person was asking so
that by itself is already turning into a
validation accreditation or are some
type of credential and then if you've
got peer feedback on hey look you know
this person is a nine out of ten at
explaining concepts if I was a
university admissions officer or HR
department at a company I would care
about that probably even more than just
the raw numbers and probably the most
important aspect is the portfolio of
creative works I mean now when we hire
at Khan Academy and and I'm selfishly
here because really I'm hoping to hire
at least half of you the the the the
number one thing we care about is what
have you made can you show us something
hey is there an app is there a website
and it doesn't have to be soft word you
have a painting even that speaks volumes
to us that you're capable of starting
with a blank slate and and and creating
something out of scratch so the
credentials of the future and we're
actually trying to make our profile into
this is yes it's gonna have badges
eventually validated badges that you
know algebra calculus
it'll have evidence that you can
participate and communicate with people
and and and and contribute to a
community but it'll also have your
portfolio of creative works even today
on our computer science platform you can
create little code and little games and
screen whatever you want other people
will give you feedback you know it's
like a code review then you put it in
your profile and that - I look at
people's profiles like wow this person
we've actually hired or we're going on
to people based purely on stuff that
they've done on their computer science
scratchpad I'm looking at the time and
it looks like I only have time for one
more questions before before we get
questions from other people for their
audience and an alumni you know you
mentioned EDX and the online movement
and MIT X and what we're doing and how
do you see how do you imagine a future
in which what we're doing in higher
education coexist with Khan Academy how
do we help each other how do we do
things that helps Society and and and
what's the impact of
visa you think we'll have in higher
education yeah you know an actually our
team was just visiting with that ex just
just right before this are you doing any
good was that are there doing any good I
think they're doing a lot of good yes
absolutely
and I mean what what and we are I think
there's a million ways that we can we
can work together and really push the on
you know our mission is a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere that's edx's mission we're
not-for-profit EDX is not for profit we
want to be a catalyst for rethinking how
classrooms are architected EDX is a
catalyst for rethinking how classrooms
are architected so I think there's a lot
you know EDX is right now primarily
higher education we're right now the
meat is still I would say in k-12 we
have a little bit in the early
university level but I think there's a
very natural transition where you know
students learn on Khan Academy are you
ready now for an EDX course maybe you
earn something on EDX maybe that could
become part of your Khan Academy profile
you know there's a million in one ways
where I think we can and should try to
move this for this mission together I
mean we want to [ __ ] we want to work
with EDX to figure out and you to figure
out you know what what can classrooms
look like at MIT or what could what good
courses or learning experiences look
like in five or ten years so yeah I'm
super pumped about about the
possibilities there it's not I'm gonna
I'm gonna get off the stage and have a
vice president : brother to join the
stage and receive question from you you
know pleasure charge no real honor thank
you thank you
[Applause]
yes so I'm gonna follow up on the
question that president rife just asked
you he asked about the Khan Academy and
EDX coexisting and man who Lohia has
tweeted but what about the
not-for-profit EDX and Khan coexisting
with the for-profit paid models so you
know extending that last answer what's
the role of the for-profit paid models
in the in this general scheme so I think
it's you know there's I mean especially
in the higher education you've had this
whole MOOC development massively open
online courses and EDX is there you of
course Sarah you have Udacity and at a
high level it's it's awesome that all of
this is happening you know once again
our mission a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere it looks like that's
what everyone is doing right now so I
think that's positive and and the more
people that have access to this the
better so I think it's definitely going
to be a model of coexistence
I do think once you start getting into
more for like literate sensitive areas
you're collecting people's data this is
sensitive data this could be data that
determines whether they get a job or not
this is data on you know what their
ability levels are on you know things
like credentials you we haven't seen I
mean it's funny even back in my hedge
fund days I've to a you know a few of
these for-profit publicly traded
for-profit universities and they talk
about all the things that they're doing
that you know and actually I can't judge
them I mean I haven't been there they're
also very proud about their analytics at
recruiting students and getting student
loans and you know they've obviously
gotten into trouble for that
well then I often ask a question if I
really want to put on the spot are you
sending your kids to this university I'm
like no where's your kids going you know
Stanford you know whatever and and when
the CEO of an organization does not want
to send their kids to that organization
that's a and I'm not saying that that's
happening in the for-profit MOOCs I
think the for-profit MOOCs are much more
they have a more altruistic mission
but when you have investors and I
thought I saw this at hedge funds when
you have investors you you the they do
want a return and they will give you a
free pass for two three four years but
they won't in year five and if they
don't like if they don't agree with them
you might go so it
that the for-profits can stay true to
the the the altruistic spirit I'm not
sure whether it'll be be able to be
maintained and whether they might not
get tempted by hey wait we you know we
need to pay our bills let's sell this
data to a telemarketer we need to pay
our bills way these people are gonna
acquire us you know who cares if they're
if they you know their other business or
XY and Z so I think those are just some
of the dangers that have to be looked
out for indeed and and and for the
record that the : vendor family are big
users of Conoco very very good so you
mentioned in an answer to a question
that President rife asked you
I think you said that five years from
now there won't be engineering lectures
at MIT so what will there be there you
know I I think did I say that I think
you okay I'm Twitter quite like when you
talked about J Lo's genes no well you
know if that happens and what I believe
it should be replaced with is I think
MIT and you know actually you know Olin
College faint you know I think they're
really pioneering some of this and and
and and I person would love to see MIT
move in this direction you know everyone
here is a creator I mean I I cringe when
someone says you know I'm not good at
engineering I'm creative like what is
engineering engineering by definition is
creating something that has never
existed before there is nothing that
someone can major in that is more
fundamentally creative I mean I read a
book like you know we we need less
engineers we need more inventors like
what is an engineer
an engineer by definition is an inventor
it's the most creative thing that you
can do but I think it would be amazing
if MIT could move in that direction
where when you graduate yeah I mean you
could have some credentials you know I
know signal processing I know circuits
and whatever else but the really
valuable thing is what did you make and
even today when we're interviewing
candidates from MIT from Stanford from
top engineering schools you know if you
get a high GPA and you know that'll get
past the resume screen but what really
we find intriguing and we don't really
care where you went if you could send us
some links to some stuff you've made if
you if you walk in the door and you can
show us something that's what sells us
and I think in the future that's gonna
sell more and more people and so I would
love MIT instead of you go to a
classroom with 300 people and I know
there's only only the introductory
courses are more in that way but even
some of the later ones they're still
lecture based instead you're your meet
together sometimes you do individual
projects sometimes you do group projects
you collaborate you do a lot of peer to
peer if while building your robot or
composing your sonata or whatever it
might be you say wait but I need to
understand solved you know go talk to a
signal the single processing guy over
there like oh really and then you could
use EDX or Khan Academy or a textbook or
the the grad student down the hall say
wait I have this problem and he said oh
watch this video and then come back to
me if you have some questions you
watched it oh wait now I understand how
to solve this problem in engineering you
go do it but it's all about going and
building things and so I think would be
incredible if it were in a reality where
everything you do at conic at MIT is
fully interactive you have resources
like EDX like Khan Academy to help you
as you see fit
you're working with the professors
working with your fellow peers and when
you walk out the most important part of
your of your experience and I'd argue
this is already the case is people
haven't realized it the most important
part of your experience is is is what
you have made
and I I assume that when you talk to MIT
students about those ideas they get very
excited right they they they have to
resonate with this notion of the
exciting opportunities that you just
described yeah I hope so and I you know
I I would say that you know and I you
know I love this place to death but I
think the one thing that that happens
here
is it's an intense environment you know
and and and and there is a little bit of
like hey you know this is like the Navy
SEALs for intellectual work you know
that's and I think that's why Frank a
lot of people here do form the type of
bonds that frankly I've only seen out of
people out of the military so it's kind
of a I don't know I mean literally we've
been through something together but that
does sometimes squeeze out the time that
you need to say hey wait I've got an
idea for this could be a cool invention
or I've got you know I have an idea for
a novel I want to write or you know I
think I can solve that problem in the
world you know I just read a new story
about people who don't have water I
think I think I have a way to solve that
and so I think you do need space you
know I I call it I am I have to say some
of my most memorable and deepest
learning experiences at MIT word during
IEP yeah so one of one of the questions
here is basically how do you do it so
the question is what steps or approaches
do you use to master such a wide array
of diverse topics so deeply how do you
do it well I mean going back to a
president rice first question I mean I
think the you know what happens here at
MIT makes you good at learning fairly
dense things in a very deep way very
very fast but you're really good oh yeah
what's you know practice 10,000 hours
knock you know although that type of
thing you know I I think I got I was
able to continue that in my hedge fund
career I mean I just described literally
every day I would be talking to five
different industries and I when I got on
the phone that person should think that
I've been I've been in all I am the oil
I literally would introduce myself yeah
I'm the oil analyst at Khan Academy and
at wool capital then the next hour oh
yeah I'm the produce analyst a wool
capital oh I'm the retail analyst so I
had to talk with that fluency and so
that was also very good preparation and
you know I think just my I love learning
I mean I used to when I graduated I said
you know if there was just a PhD and
learning everything I would do that you
know that I was all about doing that if
I could just like learn everything and
and so you know now I feel like I found
that job that lets me do that
but yeah I mean I guess it's you know I
just enjoy it and I'm doing it a lot so
uh and I'll also say you know people
like wait okay I can understand you're
doing math and finance and computer
science that's your back but what about
history I mean like once a like but what
I mean my personal belief is if you know
if you're someone who grew up always
wanting to draw connections and always
wanting to underline the conceptual
understanding you take that same mindset
onto any field of study and it's going
to be able to allow you to digest it and
so you know - there's a question why do
people you know I don't like the history
videos I think it's because I don't just
say hey this happened I do try to to say
well why would this happen and what this
doesn't make sense like there's and so I
think people appreciate that that
constant skepticism and and I think
there's also an advantage sometimes of
you know obviously there's an advantage
of being a deep expert and we want to
get those on the site as well but
there's also I think sometimes an
advantage of the person who just learned
it's like you know what I've been
wondering for the last week why this is
so I finally figured out or someone just
told me great so Benjamin Levy says can
the Khan Academy help close the
achievement gap knowing that Khan
Academy environment facilitates learning
for self-motivated students so it's well
there's two ways to do it well there's
two there's two ways to think about it
one you know I said earlier I don't
think it is just for self-motivated
students if you are a student at a Boys
& Girls Club in an inner-city we think
Khan Academy is actually the appropriate
tool we've been piloting with some
charter schools in Oakland and these
were kids entering in algebra and we saw
from the data some of these kids didn't
know their multiplication tables and in
a traditional classroom there was no way
for them to address that they would just
get insecure embarrassed about their
weaknesses they'll disengage from class
we found that if you allow someone to
address their weaknesses in a safe way
where they don't have to feel
embarrassed I don't have to raise their
hand and say wait I don't I don't I
don't know what 7 times 6 is you let
them do it in private we're seeing those
students that 80% of students that most
people think are disengaged unmotivated
become engaged become motivated and
often time accelerated they can they can
become the the best
in the class so I I think it's it's not
just hey throw a tool at a kid
especially a kid who's already been
discouraged in a traditional model for
years and years and years and have all
sorts of gaps it's can this to be used
by other stakeholders in that person's
life to allow them to accelerate their
their learning on top of that that we do
at tons of people who are about to go
into community college you say look I
didn't know math my whole life this is
right I'm gonna take ownership now but
there is an issue today and and the one
issue is an issue of awareness and
access you know the the unfortunate
thing is today if I go to if I go to
Google's campus and I say hey who uses
Khan Academy with their kids like almost
everyone raises their hand if I go to
parents group in an inner-city someplace
and it's not a Khan Academy event and I
say who uses Khan Academy like you know
one or two people and I'm like what what
is that I'm like no no we're a free
tutor for you you know like I mean
they're people you know they're fluent
are paying $100 per hour for tutors what
we can we think we can give your kids
something for free so that they can at
least start to compete you know the
thing I point out you know that Bill
Gates can afford tutors but but he still
uses you know I I don't know what else
uses with it but and so we can tell the
parent who can't afford a fancy tutor
look look even people who can't afford
tutors are using this so this isn't like
something that's going to shortchange
your kids and then of course there's the
issue of just access broadband access
computer access I think that's going to
be solved very quickly in the u.s. TV
and write broadband or merging
computation is merging I think in the
developing world it's going to take you
know we're it half a decade to a decade
for that to be come ubiquitous enough so
that last answer you you said a couple
of really amazing things one is that in
the space of one class you can change a
person's life I mean you can take a
person from being a low achiever I think
you said to the best in the class that's
amazing you know we're and then the
second thing is and yet in this you
don't have to go very far from this
auditorium to find communities that that
aren't even aware of this so I guess my
question to you is what can we do to
help make help people be aware have
what's what's mi t--'s role in all this
I mean what I find what I think would be
incredible is and James who leads are
probably actually James can you stand up
is James here Oh James right over there
yeah yeah so James leads our partnership
so he's the right guy to connect with on
this but we would love I mean the
student groups formed around the Kahn
Academy
those student groups could do a million
different things they could they could
work with our schools team go to
surrounding schools and help teachers
use Khan Academy they themselves could
become the coaches and work with
after-school programs in the area use
Khan Academy and trained other people to
use Khan Academy they can obviously you
know where we're in like we're literally
in the mecca of learning of the world in
in you know with Boston you have MIT you
have Harvard you have so many
universities here they can go and try to
get and it doesn't have to be a fancy
you know Nobel Prize winning professor
it could be the students themselves
let's see if we can generate some
content here let's see if we can help
write exercises so so there's a there's
a you know awareness content creation
helping teachers make a transition all
of the above okay well I I took that
very much to heart this notion that our
own student groups and and other
assemblies of people at MIT can make a
serious difference last question is a
complete softball you must get it asked
all the time
what's your favorite lecture oh I
thought you're gonna ask me why I look
like Ray Romano but that was a
the cousins the the no favorite lecture
I mean you know it's kind I don't think
I have a favorite lecture I mean as I
said I literally in my head that my
favorite one is the one I'm about to do
which isn't actually an uplifting topic
I'm about to do the Nazi invasion of
Poland which is not uplifting but the
but it's interesting so I don't laugh
before that one actually I don't laugh
but you know I mean there's a ton of fun
ones I mean there's some kind of
intellectual journeys I mean you know
that whenever we show video montage we
always showed the Euler's identity and
and I you know I literally and it was a
spontaneous thing when I was doing the
video and I said you know if this
doesn't blow your mind cuz it really is
mind blowing you know you have no
emotion and and and and that was you
know I had known Euler's identity yeah
you know since high school but through
Khan Academy I had the space in my life
to actually go through the the journey
of kind of discovering Euler's identity
and you know they're doing the Taylor
expansions and and it is beautiful you
have these puzzle pieces fit together
you know the trig functions coming from
the ratios of sines of right triangles
you have pie you know ratio of
circumference of a circle to the
diameter you have E which is showing up
on you know continuously compounding
interest and exponential growth
continuous exponential growth I which is
like you know this thing squared is
negative one it just works you know
these completely crazy things like BAM
that plus one is zero like you just you
chills through your spine like it's like
it's like a mystical name so yeah yeah
and that's just one I mean there's all
sorts of stuff that I'm rediscovering I
mean I already some of them I was
already excited about but I'm
rediscovering them and there are I mean
some of the math and does even the
history you start seeing patterns and
it's mystical it's yeah it just gives
you it gives you it gives you chills
yeah thermodynamics same experience it
did it does give you chills yes well are
you trying to be punished
and I never mind the yes mr. kaan Thank
You mr. Coulter thank you
thank you very much yes
[Applause]
just some quick concluding remarks first
of all thank you to all of you for
coming to this event an event that was
hosted by start labs in General Catalyst
William will Murr Hale is hosting a
private reception those of you with
tickets to that reception can head over
to the Stata Center we are at capacity
on that so I regret if you don't have a
ticket
we can't accommodate but that will give
people ticket holders an opportunity to
hear a bit more from Sal and from the
entire Khan Academy team as an added
bonus however I can offer Khan Academy
t-shirts in the lobby they are there you
can pick them up and and walk out with
them so once again south thank you thank
you to all of you
[Applause]